we're sharing an update to a very
personal story from a member of our cbs
news team
last year we told you about producer
rodney hawkins
and his family's efforts to restore
their ancestral cemetery in east texas
it's one of many projects across the
country aimed at preserving
historic black burial sites rodney is
also digging deeper into his family's
past with the help of researchers at
stephen f austin state university
their ambitious goal find records of
every enslaved person in texas
before and after they were freed in
1865.
as rodney shows us it could help
millions trace their ancestry
let us all pray together
what started as a simple search for
family history a year ago
is becoming a multi-generational journey
of self-discovery good to see you
family members came from all over the
country to complete the restoration of
our nearly two century-year-old cemetery
old mount gillian like my great uncle
billy curl
from los angeles this is the one
that i was named after bill curl
that's my namesake bill curl a
sharecropper was my great great
grandfather
last year we found his grave bringing to
life unexpected memories
for my granny it was wonderful you had
your grandma on there and your grandma
talked about who her parents were and
then she found her grandfather
we were then able to go and find him in
the records
linda reynolds and kyle ainsworth are
digging deep into the archives at
stephen f
austin state university there are 182
576 slaves in texas in the 1860 census
wait say that again yeah 182
576. they're digitizing the records for
each enslaved person registered as
property in texas they call it the lone
star slavery project
why is it just now getting done somebody
has to be interested in wanting to do it
where did my curl family come from i
have a feeling inside of these books
you're about to tell me a great story
we begin with the bill of cell from 1842
i do buy here sell and transfer 5
900 for 14 slaves including
richard a negro boy aged about
20 years so if i'm thinking right that
richard
is my great great great granddad
yeah um i'm getting kind of emotional
reading this
just because um
i'm sorry despite this being
a document that shows my
ancestor as an asset it still documents
that he existed
your reaction is the whole reason to do
the research
they found many more priceless documents
we shared them with some of richard's
oldest living descendants
my granny carl and heard great on
ironell maxie
and great uncle billy curl this is the
first document
starting with the bill of cell there are
two things
one is i want to cry and i'm trying my
best not to
and the second one is that's my slave
name i'd like to know where what my
african name is
i don't know i have a history now
it's not even understandable
these documents including richard's 1867
voter registration
help us understand how far we've come
and how far we have yet to go
i remember going to the polls with my
father
he had to recite the alphabet
before they would let him vote that's
humiliating
and he did it and paid two dollars
for his poll tax i'll never forget that
we're restoring the cemetery to honor
our ancestors who endured for us to be
here
my cousin sonny tomlin sites drove from
houston
to thank them it's just special to be
able to
pay respect right that's the thing
paying
respect we don't have generational
wealth
we are not millionaires we're not
wealthy people
but we have a home and i call that our
legacy
there's much more work to do for all
those who have shown up we thank you
and we pray we can continue to restore
our legacy
for generations to come for cbs this
morning
rodney hawkins nacogdoches texas
wow here's a standing up on the back of
my neck i can understand
uh rodney's emotion when you think about
your relatives who were assets
but what i like is what rodney said it
shows that they existed
and then you can connect all the dots
when you see a beautiful family by the
way yes that's
i thought the same thing family see why
why rodney is who he is
that was so beautifully done this is
part two of the story that he told well
that's what billy curl said i have a
history
now history the other thing that struck
me was a hundred and eighty two thousand
five hundred and seventy six slaves in
texas in
1860 and voting is an issue there how
things change and how they stay the same
don't recite the alphabet people matter
people matter and it's
good